We've all shed a tear or two watching a film
— though some of us may never admit it.
If you're looking to let it all out over some
particularly poignant films, you've come to
the right place.
Bring some tissues for your issues — and
beware of spoilers! — as we take a look
at some movies sure to make you cry.
The Iron Giant
This 1999 animated classic tells the story
of young Hogarth Hughes and his metal-eating
buddy as they embark on an exciting adventure
in suburban Maine in the late 1950s.
Fueled by Cold War paranoia, the U.S. military
thinks the gentle Iron Giant is a threat and
launches a nuclear missile at him — and
Hogarth's hometown.
The lovable hunk of metal, minimally but effectively
voiced by Vin Diesel, makes the ultimate sacrifice
to save the town and his new friends … but
that alone won't make you blink back tears.
Here's the kicker: having previously bonded
over Superman comics with Hogarth, the Iron
Giant imagines himself as the Man of Steel
as he soars through the sky, moments before
the nuke tears him apart:
"Superman!"
If a cartoon's never made you cry, this could
be your kryptonite.
Guardians of the Galaxy
2014's magnificent addition to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, Guardians of the Galaxy
earned a ton of praise for its charming performances,
its tongue-in-cheek take on the superhero
genre, and its bangin' soundtrack.
But it's also a major tearjerker.
Like the Iron Giant before him, giant tree
dude Groot — also minimally yet effectively
voiced by Vin Diesel — sacrifices himself
to save his friends by covering them with
an unbreakable Groot-sphere.
But the tears really start flowing when Rocket
asks Groot why he would give his life for
theirs, prompting a poignant twist on the
big guy's signature three-word mantra:
"We are Groot."
Who knew trees had such big hearts?
And who knew Vin Diesel acted better when
you gave him fewer words to say?
Up
Like the brightly colored balloons lifting
Carl's house, you probably saw this one coming
from a mile away.
Up is notorious for its unbelievably sad and
sweet opening sequence.
You go in expecting a quirky tale of a cranky
old man, his floating house, and his chubby
boy scout buddy — and then get socked in
the stomach with sentiment.
Pixar proves it's much more than that twee
tale right from the get-go, offering up a
sprawling love story in miniature, as Carl
meets Ellie, the love of his life, and we
get to see their entire relationship play
out — up to Ellie's death:
That's all in the first ten minutes.
Thanks for making us cry into our popcorn,
Pixar.
The Shawshank Redemption
This widely beloved 1994 flick is best known
for the relationship between convicts Andy
and Red, and Andy's elaborate, decades-in-the-making
escape plan.
But it's the story of elderly convict Brooks
Hatlen, released on parole after fifty years
behind bars, that will have you clutching
the Kleenex.
Despite his best efforts, Hatlen just can't
adjust to life on the outside.
"I don't like it here.
I'm tired of being afraid all the time.
I've decided not to stay."
Hatlen's entire farewell monologue is during
an ugly-cry-inducing scene — ending in his
suicide.
Just before he hangs himself in his apartment,
he carves "Brooks was here" into the ceiling
beam.
Field of Dreams
There's nothing quite like a moving father-son
scene, but it's made even more powerful in
a film like Field of Dreams.
After receiving visions and hearing voices
in his head, Iowa corn farmer Ray Kinsella
constructs a baseball diamond that magically
draws in one very special player: Ray's dead
father, John.
We won't give away too much of the context,
but the pain of Ray's journey to see his father
once more and to have him beam with pride
will reduce you to a puddle of tears.
As with most films on our list, a single line
will stab you right in the chest:
"You wanna have a catch?"
"I'd like that."
And … cue the ugly man-tears.
The LEGO Movie
Yes, a movie about plastic dudes battling
an evil Will Ferrell is a tearjerker.
And like Field of Dreams, it's all about daddy
issues.
In an unexpectedly moving twist, the imagination
of a real-life boy, Finn, is revealed to be
responsible for the brick-based hijinks of
the animated story.
Finn's father realizes his son's made-up antagonist,
President Business, is actually based on him,
his perfectionism, and his less-than-stellar
parenting skills.
He asks Finn what his protagonist, Emmet,
would say to President Business, and the response
will punch you right in the feelings.
"You are the most talented, most interesting,
and most extraordinary person in the universe."
The tears really start to flow when Finn tells
his father "You can change everything."
Ooh boy.
Time to call dad.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!